>>> NEW VIDEO, TODAY, FROM "THE
NEW YORK TIMES" SHOWS -- SHOWING
WHAT HAPPENED TO CAPITOL POLICE
OFFICER BRIAN SICKNICK DURING
THE JANUARY-6th RIOT.
THE VIDEO SHOWS OFFICER SICKNICK
BEING SPRAYED WITH A CHEMICAL
IRRITANT, WHILE HE HELD THE LINE
AGAINST THE VIOLENT MOB.
THAT, AS PROSECUTORS RELEASE
COMMUNICATIONS ALLEGEDLY SHOWING
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE
PARAMILITARY GROUP, THE OATH
KEEPERS, AND THE FAR-RIGHT PROUD
BOYS.
CNN'S JESSICA SCHNEIDER HAS THE
STORY.
>> Reporter: TONIGHT, WE ARE
GETTING OUR FIRST GLIMPSE OF
CAPITOL POLICE OFFICER, BRIAN
SICKNICK, IN THE HOURS BEFORE HE
DIED ON THE FRONT LINES,
GUARDING THE WEST SIDE OF THE
CAPITOL JANUARY 6th.
IN NEW VIDEO FROM "THE NEW YORK
TIMES," THE MOMENTS BEFORE AND
AFTER SICKNICK WAS HIT WITH A
CHEMICAL SPRAY PLAY OUT.
YOU CAN SEE ONE OF THE TWO MEN
ACCUSED OF ASSAULTING OFFICER
SICKNICK AND TWO OTHER OFFICERS,
JULIAN KHATER, STANDING NEARBY
IN THE CROWD.
IN ANOTHER ANGLE, YOU CAN SEE
THE PROXIMITY OF KHATER AND
OFFICER SICKNICK.
THEN, KHATER IS SEEN RAISING
WHAT "THE TIMES" IDENTIFIES A AS
A SPRAY CAN.
YOU CAN SEE, OFFICER SICKNICK
SUDDENLY TURN AWAY, AFTER BEING
STRUCK BY THE SPRAY.
AND START TO MOVE AWAY FROM THE
CROWD.
PROSECUTORS, PREVIOUSLY,
RELEASED THESE PICTURES OF THE
OFFICERS HUDDLED TOGETHER, AND
HUNCHED OVER.
THEY SAY, THREE WERE HIT, AND
ALL WERE TEMPORARILY BLINDED.
OFFICER SICKNICK, LATER
COLLAPSED IN AN OFFICER, AND
DIED AT THE HOSPITAL THE NEXT
DAY.
THE MEDICAL EXAMINER HAS NOT,
YET, RELEASE THE THE CAUSE OF
HIS DEATH.
AND THE ROLE THE CHEMICAL SPRAY
PLAYED IS STILL IN QUESTION.
BUT MICHAEL SHERWIN, THE
FORMER-ACTING U.S. ATTORNEY IN
D.C., WHO LED THE RIOT
INVESTIGATION FOR THE PAST TWO
MONTHS, SAID IT IS POSSIBLE THAT
KHATER AND GEORGE TANIOS, THOUGH
ONLY CHARGED WITH ASSAULT NOW,
COULD EVENTUALLY BE CHARGED WITH
MURDER.
>> IF EVIDENCE DIRECTLY RELATES
THAT CHEMICAL TO HIS DEATH,
YEAH, WE HAVE CAUSATION.
WE HAVE A LINK.
YES.
IN THAT SCENARIO, CORRECT,
THAT'S A MURDER CASE.
>> Reporter: MEANWHILE, THE
POSSIBLE COORDINATION BETWEEN
FAR-RIGHT GROUPS, THE PROUD BOYS
AND OATH KEEPERS, IN ADVANCE OF
JANUARY 6th, IS BEING EXPOSED BY
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS.
A NEW COURT FILING LAYS OUT THE
FACEBOOK MESSAGES FROM ALLEGED
OATH KEEPER KELLY MEGGS SAYING
HE ORCHESTRATED A PLAN WITH THE
PROUD BOYS.
IT IS THE FIRST TIME PROSECUTORS
HAVE PUBLICLY LINKED THE
ALLEGEDLY VIOLENT EFFORTS OF THE
TWO RIGHT-WING EXTREMIST GROUPS
AND DOCUMENTED THEIR ALLEGED
PREPLANNING.
IN ONE MESSAGE, MEGGS ALLEGEDLY
WRITES OF THE PROUD BOYS, I HAVE
BEEN COMMUNICATING WITH THE
LEADER.
WE ARE GOING TO MARCH WITH THEM
FOR A WHILE.
THEN, FALL BACK TO THE BACK OF
THE CROWD AND TURN OFF.
THEN, WE WILL HAVE THE PROUD
BOYS GET IN FRONT OF THEM.
WE WILL COME IN BEHIND ANTIFA,
AND BEAT THE HELL OUT OF THEM.
>> THIS IS VERY POWERFUL
EVIDENCE THAT -- THAT INDICATES
CONVERSATIONS, CONTACT, AND NOT
JUST THAT, BUT AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE TWO GROUPS ON THINGS, LIKE
TACTICS, AND POSITIONING.
>> Reporter: IN A FACEBOOK
MESSAGE FROM DECEMBER 22nd, TWO
WEEKS BEFORE THE INSURRECTION,
PROSECUTORS SAY MEGGS PLANNED
FOR 50 TO 100 OATH KEEPER
MEMBERS TO TRAVEL TO WASHINGTON.
AND THEN, WROTE, PLUS, WE EHAVE
MADE CONTACT WITH PB AND THEY
ALWAYS HAVE A BIG GROUP, FORCED
MULTIPLIER.
THREE DAYS LATER ON CHRISTMAS,
MEGGS ALLEGEDLY LAID OUT THE
GEAR MEMBERS SHOULD BRING.
D.C. IS NO GUNS, SO MACE AND GAS
MASKS, SOME BATONS.
IF YOU HAVE ARMOR, THAT'S GOOD.
PROSECUTORS ARE LAYING OUT THIS
EVIDENCE OF COORDINATION BETWEEN
THE PROUD BOYS AND THE OATH
KEEPERS.
BUT THEY'RE STILL NOT ALLEGING A
FULL-FLEDGED CONSPIRACY.
INSTEAD, SEVERAL MEMBERS OF EACH
GROUP ARE FACING THEIR OWN
CONSPIRACY CHARGES.
BUT THAT'S FOR THE ACTIONS THEY
ALLEGEDLY TOOK WITHIN THEIR OWN
GROUPS.
DON.
>> THANK YOU, JESSICA.
APPRECIATE THAT.
JOINING ME NOW, CNN LEGAL
ANALYST, ELIE HONIG.
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US, AS
WELL.
GOOD EVENING TO YOU.
YOU HEARD THE EVIDENCE.
PROSECUTORS SAY IT PROVES A HIGH
DEGREE OF COMMUNICATION AND
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE OATH
KEEPERS AND THE PROUD BOYS,
BEFORE THAT RIOT ON JANUARY 6th
AT THE CAPITOL.
HOW SIGNIFICANT IS THIS NEW
EVIDENCE?
>> YEAH, DON, SO THE CONSPIRACY
CHARGES ARE GOING TO BE
ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT HERE.
FIRST OF ALL, THEY ARE GOING TO
ALLOW THE PROSECUTORS TO TELL
THE JURY AND THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC, THE WHOLE STORY.
HOW WAS THIS PLANNED?
WHO WAS IN ON IT BEFOREHAND?
WHO WAS TALKING TO WHO?
HOW WERE THEY COMMUNICATING?
HOW WERE THEY FINANCED, IF AT
ALL?
AND MARK MY WORDS, DON, THESE
CONSPIRACY CHARGES ARE GOING TO
CAUSE THESE GUYS TO COOPERATE.
THEY'RE GOING TO FLIP AGAINST
EACH OTHER, LIKE PANCAKES.
I HAVE SEEN IT HAPPEN.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
THERE WAS A LOT OF BRAVADO.
A LOT OF TOUGH-GUY TALK, THAT
DAY.
FLAGS WAVING.
PROUD BOYS.
OATH KEEPERS.
WHEN YOU GET ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE VERSUS, FROM THE UNITED
STATES, WATCH HOW QUICKLY THEY
COOPERATE AGAINST EACH OTHER AND
GIVE PROSECUTORS THE FULL STORY.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE COMMUNICATION
RELEASED TODAY?
COULD IT RISE TO THE LEVEL OF
C
CONSPIRACY?
>> SURE.
CONSPIRACY REALLY JUST MEANS AN
AGREEMENT.
A MEETING OF THE MINDS, BETWEEN
ANY-TWO PEOPLE TO COMMIT A
CRIME.
SO, I THINK, CONSPIRACY IS
REALLY GOING TO BE THE LEAST OF
THEIR WORRIES HERE.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO SEE EVEN
MORE SERIOUS CHARGES.
LOOK, SEDITION CHARGES COULD BE
IN PLAY HERE.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A BIG WORD BUT IT
MEANS TRYING TO INTERFERE WITH
ANY GOVERNMENTAL FUNCTION.
WHY DO YOU THINK THEY WERE THERE
ON JANUARY 6th?
BECAUSE THEY WERE COUNTING THE
ELECTORAL VOTES.
THAT'S A GOVERNMENT FUNCTION.
EVEN TRYING TO TAKE OVER A
GOVERNMENT BUILDING IS SEDITION.
SO IT WOULDN'T SURPRISE AT ALL
IF WE SEE SEDITION CHARGES AS
WELL AS CONSPIRACY CHARGES.
>> GOOD TO KNOW.
SOMEONE SHOULD TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS.
THIS IS THE ALLEGED
COMMUNICATION FROM THE LEADER OF
THE OEATH KEEPERS, TO MEMBERS O
HIS GROUP.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAYS.
TRUMP SAYS IT'S GOING TO BE
WILD.
IT'S GOING TO BE WILD.
HE WANTS US TO MAKE IT WILD.
THAT'S WHAT HE IS SAYING.
HE CALLED US ALL TO THE CAPITOL,
AND HE WANTS US TO MAKE IT WILD.
SIR, YES, SIR.
GENTLEMEN, WE ARE HEADING TO
D.C.
PACK YOUR S -- SHIT, THAT'S WHAT
HE SAID.
SO, DOES THAT IMPLICATE THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, IN ANY WAY?
>> YEAH, DONMENT Y.
YOU KNOW WHAT THIS RELATES TO?
REMEMBER DONALD TRUMP'S TWEET
ADVERTISING THE JANUARY-6th
RALLY, DONALD TRUMP SAID, WILL
BE WILD.
HE
HERE IS THE PEOPLE WHO END UP
STORMING THE CAPITOL ECHOING
THAT LANGUAGE, EXACTLY.
AND LET'S NOT LOSE FOCUS ON
DONALD TRUMP HERE.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
INDICTMENTS.
OVER 300, SO FAR, IN THIS CASE.
CHARGES.
THAT'S GOOD.
THAT IS PROGRESS BY DOJ.
BUT LET'S REMEMBER TO HOPE
MERRICK GARLAND TO HIS PROMISE.
HE'S ONLY BEEN IN OFFICE TWO
WEEKS BUT WHEN HE WAS CONFIRMED,
AT HIS TESTIMONY, HE SAID WE
WILL FOLLOW EVERY LEAD, FROM THE
GO
GROUND ON UP, WHEREVER IT TAKES
US.
SO DONALD TRUMP HAS SOME REAL
CULPABILITY HERE.
WILL IT RISE TO THE LEVEL OF
LEGAL LIABILITY?
THAT'S GOING TO BE A VERY BIG
QUESTION FOR-MERRICK GARLAND TO
ANSWER.
BUT EVIDENCE LIKE THIS DOESN'T
HELP DONALD TRUMP AT ALL.
>> WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THAT
ASSAULT ON THAT OFFICER
SICKNICK.
OKAY.
TWO MEN HAVE ALREADY BEEN
CHARGED WITH ASSAULT.
IF PROSECUTORS CAN PROVE THE
BEAR SPRAY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
HIS DEATH, WHAT THEN?
MURDER?
>> IF THEY PROVE THAT.
IF THE AUTOPSY AND THE
TOXICOLOGY, WHICH IS THE BLOOD
ANALYSIS, COME BACK AND TIE THE
BEAR SPRAY TO THE DEATH.
THEN, YES, I BELIEVE WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT A MURDER CHARGE.
THAT NEW VIDEO IS SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE, WHAT IT DOES, IS IT
TAKES AWAY ANY DEFENSE THIS
INDIVIDUAL MAY HAVE.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY NOT SELF-DEFENSE.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY INTENTIONAL.
IT'S NOT AN ACCIDENTAL
DISCHARGE.
HE DOESN'T FIRE INTO A CROWD.
HE ASKS FOR THE BEAR SPRAY, FROM
HIS FRIEND.
HE GETS IT.
HE HOLDS IT UP OVER HIS HEAD AND
SHOOTS IT DIRECTLY INTO OFFICER
SICKNICK'S FACE.
IF THEY GET THAT SCIENTIFIC LINK
TO THE DEATH, THEN I BELIEVE WE
WILL SEE A MURDER CHARGE.
>> THERE'S BEEN LOTS OF TALK
ABOUT THIS INTERVIEW ON CBS.
MICHAEL SHERWIN, THE
FORMER-ACTING D.C. U.S. ATTORNEY
WHO LED THE INITIAL
INVESTIGATION TOLD CBS, THE
OTHER DAY, THAT HE BELIEVES SOME
OF THE CAPITOL RIOTERS COULD BE
CHARGED WITH SEDITION.
YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT SEDITION.
DO PROSECUTORS HAVE THE EVIDENCE
TO MAKE THAT STICK, ELIE?
>> I THINK THEY DO.
I THINK, YOU LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED INSIDE THE CAPITOL.
AND LOOK.
ENTERING THE CAPITOL'S A CRIME.
YOU KNOW, UNLAWFUL ENTRY INTO
THE CAPITOL.
DESTRUCTION OF PROPERTY.
THEFT.
A LOT OF THOSE HAVE BEEN
CHARGED.
YOU EVER TO ASK THE NEXT-LAYER
QUESTION, WHICH IS WHAT WERE
THEY TRYING TO DO THERE?
WHY WERE THEY THERE JANUARY 6th?
NOT BECAUSE IT WAS A NICE,
RANDOM WEDNESDAY IN JANUARY.
IT'S BECAUSE THAT'S THE DAY,
UNDER THE LAW, UNDER THE SK
CONSTITUTION, WHERE THE
ELECTORAL VOTES WERE COUNTED.
THAT'S THEIR PURPOSE.
THAT'S WHY DONALD TRUMP CALLED
THEM THERE.
THAT'S WHY THEY STORMED THE
BUILDING.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WERE LOOKING TO
DO INSIDE.
IF THAT'S THE PURPOSE, IF YOU
CAN ESTABLISH THAT, BY ALL
MEANS, SEDITION SHOULD BE
CHARGED HERE.
PROSECUTORS SHOULD NOT BE SHY
ABOUT THIS.
PROSECUTORS HAVE TO BE FAIR BUT
THEY HAVE TO BE AGGRESSIVE.
THIS IS THE TIME TO BE
AGGRESSIVE.
>> JUST TO BE CLEAR, BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, I ASKED YOU ABOUT
CONSPIRACY AND I ASKED YOU ABOUT
SEDITION.
AND YOU HAD TWO OBVIOUSLY VERY
CONCISE ANSWERS.
WHICH ONE -- IS THERE ONE THAT'S
MORE LIKELY?
OR IS THERE POSSIBILITY OF BOTH,
HERE?
>> CONSPIRACY IS -- HAS ALREADY
BEEN CHARGED, IN SOME CASES.
AND IS A VIRTUAL CERTAINTY
BECAUSE CONSPIRACY VERY COMMON.
IF YOU LOOK AT FEDERAL
INDICTMENTS, ANYTIME TWO OR MORE
PEOPLE ARE INVOLVED AND WORK IN
CONCERT OR ANY KIND OF
AGREEMENT, YOU WILL SEE A
CONSPIRACY CHARGE.
THAT IS VERY RUN OF THE MILL.
SEDITION IS VERY RARE.
THERE IS ACTUALLY NOT BEEN A
SEDITION CHARGE, IN THIS
COUNTRY, IN OVER A DECADE.
THERE'S NOT BEEN A SUCCESSFUL
SEDITION PROSECUTION IN THIS
COUNTRY, SINCE 1995.
BY MY FORMER OFFICE, THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.
SO CONSPIRACY IS RUN OF THE
MILL.
SEDITION IS VERY RARE.
I THINK BOTH ARE WARRANTED HERE.
>> WOW.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE YOU HERE.